Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P, here's a caller with a
very specific question. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, Tony had a question
for you. So this may be like more of
a medical expert question when it comes to.
Speaker 1: David and I. Even though I am not a
medical expert, I'm glad to answer as if I were.
Speaker 2: Potential human hibernation, the
pandemic and kind of people for staying indoors
a lot a long time in the winter when it's cold,
you know, is a possibility. Like it's some
sort of like, what was it like? You get
what I'm saying? Need some topics or something?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I understand. Okay. The idea is
we've got a pandemic and in the winter it's
flu season, etc.. I have COVID right now,
as I talked about yesterday. What if I or we
when it starts to be flu season could hibernate,
could humans hibernate, skip the entire flu
season? First of all, if it were possible,
I don't know that it actually saves us from
flu season. It might just shift it around. I'm
not sure about that. Okay, that's number one.
But number two, let's talk about hibernation.
There is no evidence that is very good that
humans are able to go into hibernation,
which would be like an extended state of torpor,
I think is the way that we would say there's no
evidence of that in what would be called accepted
medical science. Right now, the idea is widely
discussed. It's been explored in science fiction.
The idea of using some kind of human hibernation
or reduced metabolic state for long space travel
has been talked about. These are not new ideas,
but there are only speculative commentaries that
it's theoretically possible you can find papers
that say, you know, ancestors to humans, you know,
pre-human ancestors had the biological mechanics
required for hibernation. And maybe with the
right technology or modifications, it's something
that humans might be able to do. You know, the
the idea of cryogenic preservation for people
so that in the future, if certain diseases
could be cured or whatever the case may be,
people could be reanimated. It's a big topic, big
business, but it is quite speculative. And that's
sort of like where the science is right now and
much is being research. But here's another thing.
Wouldn't that be very difficult socially? Because
even if you could technologically and medically
figure out human hibernation, how would that work
socially and culturally and psychologically? It
seems like it would be a really difficult thing.
I don't know. That's just my sense right now.
But an interesting question nonetheless. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: The money on the bonus show is just
crazy. You should see it on today's bonus show.
Joe Biden has the idea to make South Carolina the
first Democratic primary. What does South Carolina
think of it? We will talk about that on the bonus
show. Number two, remember Michael Avenatti. He's
been sentenced to prison for 14 years for fraud.
And it is wild, wild stuff. Our friend Barron
Cousins, who was brutally assailed by Avenatti,
is thrilled. And we will also talk about
9 million Americans who were wrongly told
that they were approved for student loan debt
forgiveness. How did it happen and what's the
story? We will talk about all of it and more
on today's bonus show, which you can access by
signing up right now. Now, you could do it later.
I would do it right now at join pass the dot com.